[Music]
tomorrow m2 will wrinkle in time and
it's a nobody starts with a trip through
the clouds cliche Disney movie
immediately fulfills its prerequisite to
include at least one Chris oh they're
girly safety first if daddy pine was
just gonna let her take off her goggles
when something cool happen why'd he'd
give him to her in the first place yes
did I actually think she's worried not
only is she the daughter of two doctors
but she's nine and hopefully not under
any impression her parents don't love
her anymore because she opens some
fucking third-rate origami also origami
shadowing meg is that predictable then
that means this has happened many times
and therefore she shouldn't have to ask
Charles Wallace the question Charles
Wallace needs to be taught the
importance of putting all the condiments
back in the fridge or someone's getting
food poisoning for more mayonnaise and
sriracha tomorrow marks the four-year
anniversary of the disappearance of NASA
scientist dr. Alex Murray finally radio
broadcast is timely
and so begins movies incessant need to
punctuate every single moment with some
sort of pop song she's walking down a
hallway for pete's sake do we really
need Kalani's input on this Jesus I know
kids can be mean but this is a whole new
level the heart over the letter I might
be the most morbid part of this note
let's just generously assume that this
is the kind of gossip teachers would be
partaking in at this school you wouldn't
do a quick spot check for any offspring
around before you start running your
mouth it's not like he's hiding he's
sitting right there if Veronica wants to
be a true mean girl she really needs to
work on insults that have a little more
merit Charles Wallace was adopted and
therefore has no blood relation to any
other Murray family so absolutely
nothing runs in his genetic makeup that
would have come from that you're next
Charles Wallace what totally understand
you can't talk back to teachers but
considering the situation and the
anniversary of their death disappearance
they can't give one of the kids a break
all I'm saying is it's been four years
odds are he's not coming back maybe the
school counselor would say this to a
student but this is a harsh thing for a
principal to put out there doesn't he
know principals are supposed to be pals
it's right there in the spelling you
nicknamed her midlet really what about
Meg pie or Meg leg or Megamind or Mickey
sue or your Mixel and see nutmeg
anything is better than Meg --let yeah
well makers can't be choosers I guess
don't worry my friend Charles Wallace
looks old enough to understand why his
mom and sister are a little weirded out
if anything he should be surprised
they're not more weird out call me mrs.
wickley mrs. who no mrs. whatsit third
base just that there really is such a
thing as a desert act movie assumes
viewer has read a book or knows what a
tesseract is also is their Disney movie
that isn't in the MCU Veronica you
really don't trust easily do you
yes mrs. whatsit under the impression
that strained women who look like they
just arrived from the fanciest toga
party ever
up here super trustful yes we know Reese
we saw you in wild stop talking to
strangers I don't talk to them they talk
to me doesn't mean you have to answer
manners math I mean stranger danger
really isn't that hard of a concept even
for a six-year-old not sure what Charles
Wallace isn't grasping here don't be
like me
that's wrong a thing like yeah every
character in this film is either a dick
or has zero sense of what other people's
personal space is Calvin aren't you that
I am what are you doing here
I don't know and neither do we Calvin
neither do we you're cold here you're
good at a policy what do we need to pull
Missy for Charles Wallace
don't know and apparently neither does
the movie this has literally never
brought up again so these women are from
wrinkles in time or whatever but
currently they're just hanging around in
a world where the laws of physics matter
and therefore the book shouldn't stack
that way Calvin American that's racist
uses other people's words some might use
the same argument against the script for
this film also you have a character that
speaks only in other people's quotes and
that's the part you hire Mindy Kaling
for just need your mind
well these professional scientists
really act this rude at a presentation
are they all asshole ologists she's
gonna tell everybody that you are here
with me and I'm just trying to protect
your reputation yeah and she can also
hear you and see that you're acting
oddly so why keep giving her ammo
Wallace do this exactly
he's been supplying Meg with crazy
riddles and irritating the anniver but
if that was what mrs. whatsit who and
witch wanted then congratulations I
guess the final piece of the puzzle
pink pronoun game needs to end now these
people have confusing names and we get
that we've got that for the last 25
minutes move on
mrs. rich is a giant can no one else in
the neighborhood see this Baraka is
conveniently not poking your head out
our window also what about mrs. hoo and
mrs. whatsit are they just prancing
around the neighborhood with no
questions asked or can they just appear
like mrs. which does this movie have a
tesseract instead of the rules I'm
pretty sure that's the one question I
can answer is there such thing as the
wrong size don't answer that Charles
Wallace it's a trap my father
sure Magus weirded out by all this as
she should be
Charles Wallace has acted like a kid
who's going to grow up to be a serial
killer and these strange women wearing
bed linens keep showing up out of
nowhere but one mention of daddy and
she's fully on board because we're
almost half an hour in and we need to
get this wrinkling in time going that's
it this whole thing movie up to this
point has been throwing around
tesseracts and now when they finally
contested here we see Meg's eyes closed
her stuck in some goo and then she wakes
up she can be any size she wants why is
final fantasy Oprah so big I'm not
saying every strange visual choice has
to be explained but explaining some of
them might help ground this fantasy into
the story and characters instead of just
feeling like a giant game of we crazy
everyone knows that flowers are the best
customers in the entire universe which
is why Reese Witherspoon never gets
blackout drunk in a field because that
will be on TMZ the next day yes in
addition to understanding English these
flowers apparently have zoom and enhance
vision as well does that picture is tiny
and her finger is covering half of it
anyway color maybe we can interpret
whatever language these flowers are
using just get Nate actually unless
you're Tobias fume que most of us
occasionally do but don't worry boy whoo
I'm still not sure is actually in this
movie it's a Disney film so you're in no
danger of seeing misses what's it's
what's its
mrs. who knows mrs. whatsit though ma'am
has most likely seen it before
so why so surprised so the kids are
riding their new cabbage dragon past
giant Oprah Einstein in the direction
pointed out by the sentient floral
arrangement then somebody took all the
drugs considering Oprah's spent probably
her entire time in front of screens
looking at tennis balls and not much
else
maybe her vague expressionless
performance should be commended really
giant gravity defying priests tickles
it's like somebody watched avatar and
thought can we do the floating mountains
but a bit more like Donuts why would she
even try this it's one thing to have
faith when someone suggests it it's
another thing to completely just assume
you know the physics of a planet you've
never been to human male channel
character who literally wandered into
this movie off the street would be
excellent at cinemasins
it's called Camazotz home to a purely
evil energy known simply as the it so
it's the nothing meets Pennywise got it
man Pennywise is popping up in more
things this past year than cardi B well
Ryan I swear these different
environments are just cutscenes from a
game I have no desire to ever play
I don't feel or say anything when you
Tessa and you won't until you become one
with the universe jewel brow Oprah's
advice in this movie is like a Chris
Pratt acceptance speech without the
pooping advice or any actual substance
you look at the person if their natural
form is not humanoid then why is happy
medium looking all human if he wasn't
even expecting guests or knew who would
entered his domain I'm sorry mrs. which
I think we need to show her something
she needs to understand what's possible
because apparently traveling to other
dimensions and flying on the back of a
leaf caterpillar wasn't fucking enough
to convince her also if there was
something definitive that would convince
her to help out and find her dad then
why not start with that through darkness
the its reach spreads far beyond Oprah's
position being a warrior can you missus
which is peeping out so much in SPO
speech in this movie that slipped into
Yoda speak she did your father sounds
like a a good man and how exactly do you
know that Zack literally the only thing
you've heard about her father is that
mrs. which thinks he can help fight the
it don't play like you know things you
don't know Galifianakis yeah like me
weirdo the beard live in a cave weirdo
with a beard living in a cave is
definitely my next band name ah
that's the frequency so the scientific
breakthrough depended on a motion that
sound you hear is a hundred thousand
actual scientists rolling their eyes at
the same time this is no longer a search
it's a rescue okay but when exactly does
it become an interesting movie pretty
sure there was a large imbalance of
costume changes to story in this movie
Camazotz
that's funny because just a couple
minutes ago I'm pretty sure you said we
can't test sir the Camazotz stick to
your own rules movie we must leave this
planet and we do not have the strength
to take you with us but we will somehow
have exactly the amount of strength it
takes to stick around just long enough
to give you this information and objects
you will need for the rest of this movie
my gift is my command that's not a gift
you stingy bossy which how is it even
possible that none of them were standing
in a spot one of the trees popped up
from these kids need to purchase lottery
tickets when they get back from tessarin
wait okay fine the kid likes to be
called by his full name but enough is
enough certainly someone like this
Calvin kid would slip up and just do it
Charles at least once so even though the
who what which and why is Gamora can't
be on this planet they all still walkie
talkie here and some echoey voices make
up your mind movie all right these kids
on their own or not I seem to have
forgotten the part in the book where the
kids run away from the smoke monster
lost also Megan Calvin have clearly gone
to the Prometheus school of running away
from things but why I'm not saying
Calvin and sobs here couldn't trust each
other I'm just saying the movie has done
zero in this first hour to help us
understand why they would have any
connection whatsoever
please survive this how did you do the
whole thing with the log just a physics
thing classic slingshot maneuver right
they teach it in physics right after the
surviving a nuclear bomb by riding it
out in the fridge lesson pretty sure
that was the character description for
the character of Calvin in the casting
call the intimidation tactics in this
neighborhood dodgeball match are off the
charts well you can't say Gloria Estefan
and the Miami Sound Machine didn't try
to warn it it is a sandwich zone thanks
for everything
you brought them right to us if they
just want to Charles Wallace this whole
time then why didn't they just come and
get all the missus GRU had no issue
getting the earth also did I miss
something why does it matter that his
eyes are red we only learned later that
the it infects its subjects with red
eyes and why is he showing Meg his eyes
at all I swear this movie thinks if it
can ask with cool visuals we will
somehow just go along for the rock also
why is he revealing himself at all can't
there just be one villain in the history
of movie kind that decides that it might
be beneficial not to be identified what
is he done T problem with Charlie
Wally's extremely sudden he'll turn here
is that he's already been fairly
annoying throughout this entire movie
and there hasn't been much of a
connection between him and Meg developed
anyhow oh and did I mention it's
extremely sudden so Charles Wallace just
went from overly gleeful to borderline
psycho in 60 seconds how exactly did
this happen because he passed the sam
test thank you also this could have been
the subtitle for the movie a wrinkle in
time a ridiculous journey with people
you barely know what do you see Papa
logic order fractal dimension another
science II sounding words duh damn it
movie this actually could have been the
only somewhat cool and emotional moment
in the film did we really need shot aid
come along and sadly sing lines from the
movie also wasn't she only seeing this
fractal dimension because she had her
whatsit goggles on how is she still
seeing it enough to make this trip
without them did she instantly memorize
the layout this is a trick considering
how many times he's probably been
tricked it makes sense that Alex would
think this but why doesn't make the last
25 minutes of this movie has pretty much
just been her getting bamboozled
he does realize his kid is a few years
older though right this shouldn't be too
hard to deduce if the CW could do this
then why didn't he do it just a few
seconds ago to keep Meg from going in
and finding their dad major character
gets possessed by a dark entity develops
superhuman powers and in a third person
grant claims they aren't here anymore
cliche the darkness how does he know
these arbitrary rules
is there a tessarin guidebook you
receive once you figure out the science
if the it's plan is to send a different
version of Meg back then why didn't the
same thing happen Alex I have to say out
of all the movies I thought this film
was still from The Exorcist wasn't one
of the but this is some of the best
counterfeit Pazuzu I've ever seen so
when they said you were going to be
taken by the darkness I didn't realize
they meant the screen would be so dark I
can't see anyone's face not that I need
to I'm sure Charlie boy is still looking
smug and evil and Meg still has that
confused weepy thing going on so carry
on so let me guess love is the answer
love will bring us together all we need
is love love is a many-splendored thing
I'm not even saying it's not worth
believing I'm just saying the movie is
keeping all this dark light evil love
stuff so surface that it doesn't even
have a chance to really resonate much
deeper than a fortune cookie Charles
Wallace your light has returned yeah but
the missus said specifically they could
not travel here because of all the
darkness right but hey convenient
semantics I'm so proud of you Meg the
universe is bright tonight because of
you why as mrs. who was still speaking
in her own words earlier she said it was
because the dark was weakening but isn't
she all empowered up now that the
darkness weakened this is why we leave
you not if I leave you first you can't
fire me because I quit tomorrow there'll
be more of us Maranda American I always
heard Madeleine L'Engle is a huge Sex in
the City fan also why do we need more of
them we've already got whosits and
whatsits galore
it isn't we saw mr. Murray tesslar back
when Meg wouldn't leave Charles Wallace
behind but how exactly did Calvin find
his way back
is he a Tesori rear just right that's
the Raider whatever this movie can go
tesslar itself in the test role sorry
I'm late that's what you're going with
after abandoning your family for
interdimensional travel for the past
four years Wow good thing you look like
Chris Pine
[Music]
[Applause]
with the sound of music
[Music]
[Applause]
how's it going happy shouldn't be here
I'm not supposed to be within 200 feet
of a school
Oh or chuck-e-cheese I was at a wine
tasting with my cousin Ernesto it was
mainly grads and you know I don't love
raise man you know but there was a
rosette I say today it was delightful
okay you're the boss
my gift just a physics thing physics
Terry no one remember